(cheerful jingle)
- Happy Fourth of
July, Aunt Sam.
- Whoa, whoa, careful.
- Yes, are you ready,
bitch, to do this contest
'cause it is every year and
it's like the only reason
why I feel I still
am an American
despite the current
administration, are you ready?
- Yeah I was just gonna
say before you got into
your whole thing, I don't
know if I can do it.
- Did something happen, are you?
- I was boiling the dogs and
I was smelling that hot water.
- Don't tell me boiling the
dogs didn't make you want
the dogs more.
- It didn't.
I don't want the dogs.
- Okay.
- We've been doing this
for a couple years, but
this isn't fun for me.
- You know, I'm not
gonna let it get me down,
I guess I'll just
compete against myself.
- Yeah dude, this is your
thing, you are gonna kill it.
- I have seven here today,
that's all I need to beat
my own record.
- I'm gonna be
your old man.
Rocky old man.
You got this, dude, I'm gonna
watch you as much as I can.
You are skilled, you're amazing.
You are my best friend for
a reason and it's right now.
You are the representative
of our country.
You're the Statue of Liberty.
You are so talented.
- No gagging, no gagging!
- Dunk it!
That'll make it go.
You having fun?
Don't drink the dog water,
don't drink the dog water!
Oh no, dude.
You good?
- I beat my record.
(cheerful jingle)
What do you think the stripes
are in the American flag?
They're hot dogs, they're
boiled and unboiled hot dogs,
white and red and white and red.